[Musique]
c'est ce qui me fait rigoler c'est que
là il vous est lancé le ballon moi j'ai
peut-être commencer ma godasses
j'ai pas de ballons bon alors je suis
venu vous parler de liberté chemins de
traverse et combativité c'est un peu
bizarre en fait liberté c'est tout de
suite suis vraiment content parce que je
suis assez libre
j'ai une vie dirait de liberté c'est à
dire que je fais ce que je veux je pars
quand je veux bon je vis seul mais ça
c'est vraiment un choix ça je vais faire
une petite parenthèse est prévue en
répétition mais quand tu te mets
quelqu'un vers une copine le premier
truc qu'elle fait elle fait le ménage
hier elle chasse toutes les autres et
moi je suis pas d'accord donc je préfère
rester tout seul pour moi les choses
sont claires
ça c'est les libertés chacun fait ce
qu'il veut je ne fais pas de
prosélytisme
bref et aujourd'hui mon boulot bah c'est
de voyager d'aller dans tous les pays
rencontrer toutes sortes de gens pour
cette émission qui s'appelle j'irai
dormir chez vous bon c'est ça donc en
fait le but c'est de se balader comme ça
en échec des petites caméras aller la
rencontre des gens et dans tous les
milieux c'est à dire que la gt en
tanzanie puis l'été top top de chez top
et dans des milieux extrêmement variées
dans des pays variés un coup chez les
riches un coup chez les pauvres un
coucher chez les dents des pays froids
un coup dans des pays chauds
mais il ya un truc que je garde tout le
temps c'est cette satanée liberté de ne
pas savoir ce que je vais faire c'est
super important parce que quand tu sais
ce que tu vas faire
ben tu as ton programme tu sais où tu
vas et du coup tu regardes plus sur les
côtés alors que quand tu sais pas ce que
tu vas faire et battait disponible pour
rencontrer quelqu'un comme lui voilà
c'est vrai pour moi il est là mais pour
vous et en fait j'ai vraiment me suis
retrouvé dans toutes sortes de deux
milieux
et je propose qu'on regarde parce que
j'ai l'impression que je vais trop vite
par rapport à mes images
non c'est vrai ça c'est au nicaragua
c'est moi je vais faire péter un ballon
il y avait des petits ballons de
baudruche et pas des pommiers de son rsa
c'est assez improvisé un parce que j'ai
fait des répétitions j'ai pas du tout
dit la même chose parce que je m'en
rappelle plus ce que j'ai dit d'une fois
à l'autre il problème c'est que je
reconnais pas bien les gens enfin il ya
plein de trucs qui font fait cette seule
comme ça bref sa fille tu l'entends
danny pye namibie pardon heureusement
que c'est écrit un bref je suis heureux
je m'amuse
j'ai 58 ans je sais pas ce que je vais
faire mais je suis pas du tout dans
quest pour l'avenir parce que ben parce
que je crois que j'ai fini par trouver
ma place
une certaine manière alors j'ai commencé
d'une manière un peu particulière que
j'ai eu de la chance allait on est on
arrive dans une famille on n'a rien
demandé
et puis moi je suis tombé chez des
nobles
je jure c'est vrai voici le château de
la famille et puisqu'on en est à parler
un petit peu de nos vies et puis des
gens qu'on rencontre et ben riadh que
vous avez eu juste avant moi
figurez-vous que ses associés c'est mon
cousin est donc mon cousin et ben en
fait c'est un descendant de cette
famille comme moi d'ailleurs et les
petites parenthèses
bonjour lui la pendule je suis le conte
c'est pas une blague mais j'ai pas le
château est ce qu'il ya eu la révolution
donc on le donne pürro aux comptes c'est
ce kurde et ce où qu'ils rachètent mais
en même temps ça reste vraiment mon
château dans ma tête
et puis j'avais pas vraiment le temps de
m'en occuper alors moi j'ai eu la chance
dans la mesure où je suis né non
patchées des nobles mais chez mes
parents parce que mes parents mon père
il a fait une espèce de rupture avec sa
famille
non pas en se fâchant mais en voulant
vivre une autre vie et il est devenu
peintre
ma mère aussi et mes parents je vais
vous les montrer s'il fait quand même
des gens accès exceptionnel ces process
est normal d'appuyer sur ce truc main
mon papa et ma maman
alors mes parents il a une particularité
c'est déjà c'est que hiller priorité
c'était de créer de peindre et de
s'amuser
par exemple un truc qui était vraiment
pas une priorité à la maison c'était le
ménage quand vous allez voir la cuisine
vous allez comprendre
voilà la cuisine tout et que des meubles
de récupération mais des trucs et les on
ouvrait les portes elle tomber la cic 1
c'est un désordre complet bon les images
sont pas très bonnes ça date un peu et
parce que mon père et ma mère considéré
que tout minutes à faire le ménage était
perdu pour faire autre chose voilà et
mon père il rangeait pas puisqu'il
disait quand s'est rangé ses perdu voilà
il avait raison parce que retrouver
jamais et ma mère comme elle est pas
d'argent eh ben on a commencé à peindre
sur des cagettes qu'elle récupère et
dans les marchés alors parfois il ya des
cages et de carrés et elle peignait des
gens en prison alors je vous explique
elle peignait sur les lattes
mais entre les lattes il ya des espèces
dans qu'elle mettait un tissu et ça
devenait des barreaux virtuel donc à
lapins comme ça pendant des années des
gens en prison
c'est là la france veut les moyens ou
celle inverse d'ailleurs les moyens
toujours est il que quand elle a eu un
petit peu plus de sou elle a eu les
moyens d'acheter des planches ce qui lui
a permis de faire des grands tableaux de
jean toujours en prison et je peux vous
dire que mes parents n'y a pas plus
rigolo j'ai versé dès positif
vraiment et mon père lui il a trouvé
notre idée il s'est mis à faire des
petits traits entrecroisées voyez la
baule c'est que des petits traits sont
longs comme ça et plus il y avait de
petits traits puces étaient noirs et
moyens d'aller plus été pensée logique
et m'a un jour il a fait un dessin puis
on a fait un autre à côté
et puis on a fait un autre côté avec
juste les tout petits traits et ben
l'ensemble ça fait 82 mètres de long
c'était quand même un cas mon père
qu'être 22 mètres de long alors quand tu
demandes et ça ressemble à quoi bon je
vous laisse regarder qu'est ce que tu
veut définir ce truc c'est vrai c'est
super joli extrêmement original mais tu
sais pas comment tu veux appeler ça donc
il a appelé la suite on homologie
singulière suite
alors suite inexacte en homologie
singulière s'il ya un bateau il sait que
une suite exacte en or nos mauls vie
singulière ça existe mais que concernant
le travail de mon père c'était plutôt
inexactes voilà donc moi je suis né dans
un environnement où il y avait une
atmosphère particulière et surtout une
extrêmement grande ouverture d'esprit
en revanche au niveau de la structure
c'était pas ça par exemple mon père qui
a passé son permis à 46 ans qu'il a raté
cinq fois et qu'il a eu à la sixième
fois parce que le gars lui ai dit si on
vous le donne pas vous allez tous les
autres ont passé le code et qui s'est
empressé je plaisante pas de casser la
bagnole le lendemain parce qu'ils
savaient toujours pas bien conduire
c'était quelqu'un qui était quand même
un petit peu dans les dents les éthers
et donc moi quand j'ai voulu faire des
choses
il a fallu que je me reconcentre
heureusement j'avais des copains qui
étaient beaucoup plus carrés et je
regardais comment il fonctionne et c'est
comme ça que je suis devenu très
méthodique et j'ai pas l'air quand on
voit les épisodes de j'irai dormir chez
vous mais je suis très méthodique
parce que j'ai pas le choix parce que si
je suis pas en train de penser de
manière méthodique à ce que je fais
eh ben je fais que dollars dans le sens
de mes parents c'est à dire c'est à dire
que je ramène rien voilà et donc ensuite
parce qu'il faut j'accélère ont déjà eu
une minute
ensuite je me suis lancé je voulais
faire de la télé et je me suis lancée
sur des expéditions scientifiques et là
j'ai fait des trucs qui était quand même
vraiment géniaux des très très belle
expo j'ai appris plein de trucs d'un
point de vue scientifique j'ai pas fait
d'études allemand virait 17 ans après
avoir doublé la troisième
bon c'était pas tellement pour moi ça
c'est le radeau des cimes c'est un truc
absolument génial imaginez cette
plateforme elle fait 450 mètres carrés
elle est déposée par un dirigeable sur
la forêt équatoriale
la canopée c'est toujours un peu ça
passe ça passe pas et ça devient
immédiatement un laboratoire pour les
chercheurs qui montent dessus avec des
cordes et qui se retrouvent à l'endroit
où ils pouvaient jamais allé sur dix
toutes petites branches tout filmé pour
étudier le truc le plus important pour
le sur la forêt c'est dire là où il ya
la floraison les insectes tous ces trucs
là c'était donc génial
ensuite j'ai fait toutes sortes
d'expédition par exemple celle ci
s'était descendre dans des gouffres de
glace du groenland
tout ça c'était avant j'irai dormir chez
vous c'était de d'explorer ces gouffres
qui sont creusées naturellement note
dans nos dans nos montagnes à nous si on
appelle ça des moulins sauf qu'au
groenland
ils font 200 mètres de profondeur et toi
enfin moi quand je descendrai dans ce
genre de truc c'est pas trop mon genre
ça moi je les ai pas l'habitude
tu te retrouves au bout d'une corde il
ya personne avec toi parce qu'on peut et
à 15 sur la corde
et puis à l'endroit où il faut changer
de cordes c'est super compliqué tu
touches le glaçon tu te dicter par la
place d'un être humain quoi alors ça
pareil j'ai plongé en sous-marin leur
pack cela moi j'ai plongé à 5000 mètres
avec le nautile de l'ifremer
mais là pour ce film c'est
extraordinaire de sous marins qui peut
filmer l'autre
quand tu fais un film c'est
extraordinaire d'avoir des images au
fond de la mer dans était à mille mètres
les expéditions absolument incroyable et
puis alors dans la suivante j'ai
commencé à dormir dans des endroits
bizarres parce que l'autre expédition
que j'ai fait juste après c'était une
expédition dans un volcan qui se
trouvent en république démocratique du
congo
qu on appelle cela un beau jean nicolet
qu'on appelle le niera gong aux imaginer
un volcan qui fait 3500 mètres de haut
avec un cratère de 800 m je veux un peu
en avance mais on y est l'oni ragon go
pour vous mesdames et messieurs c'est
qu'il faut faire gaffe un an quand tu
commences à parler des femmes est
exactement pareil
et donc on est descendu dans ce volcan
pour aller chercher de la lawe sais pas
si vous voyez le volcan est en activité
il est pas en éruption
donc ça veut dire il un peu énervé mais
les ponts colère et il a fallu descendre
tout au fond donc 3 fois la tour eiffel
pour aller chercher de la lave on n'a
pas pu aller tout au fond des mines
cordes en travers pour aller chercher
ces échantillons de l'avs
vous voyez le genre de descente que ça
donne c'est à dire c'est pas simple et
alors pendant ce bateau on va arriver à
ce que ce dont je voulais vous parler
c'est la combativité
parce que quand tu veux obtenir quelque
chose que ce soit arrivé à faire un film
récupéré un échantillon de l'avs
quand tu as envie de faire quelque chose
comme ça il faut te battre et le premier
problème qu'on a en tant que mec qui
veut obtenir quelque chose c'est très
souvent je vous laisse quand même
regarder ça c'est beau on voulait un
petit bout de truc rouge là nous y voilà
pour compliquer en principe je peux vous
dire que ça a été dur on le premier truc
qui nous arrête c'est le doute et
surtout de se dire ça va peut-être pas
marché et en attendant souvent à vouloir
c'est un peu ce que disait rien d'aussi
on a un petit peu de tendance à vouloir
être sûrs de notre coup avant d'y aller
et moi je vais vous dire une chose il
faut il y aller
il faut y aller parce que si ça marche
pas au moins tu auras pas de regret et
ça c'est vachement important parce que
j'irai dormir chez vous je vais vous
dire une chose
personne n'en a voulu de cette série
c'est normal c'est ainsi filmé avec les
pieds oui je regarde pas dans le viseur
on peut s'attendre de ce soit bête
l'image le son c'est des petits micros
là y'a pas d'ingénieur du son quand
quelqu'un me parle très souvent j'écoute
à moitié parce que je suis en train déjà
de penser
est-ce que je suis pas dans un endroit
trop dangereux est ce qu'on va pas ma
taille et par derrière
est-ce que ce client ce mec est
intéressant à ce que je vais avoir une
belle séquence à est cuit j'essaye de
plein de choses j'ai trop de trucs à
gérer donc quand j'ai commencé à
proposer une émission où on allait voir
serrer comme ça c'est à dire plus que le
présentateur de journal de 20h un plan
sur deux et que j'ai dit ben je vais
aller rencontrer des gens je sais pas
qui est je sais pas ce que je vais faire
et je sais pas où ça les a pas rassurés
donc j'y suis allé quand même mais
j'étais pas payé alors heureusement
j'avais une maison de production qui
était derrière moi mais sauf qu'ils
étaient en train de couler parce que
cette maison de production qui porte
bien son nom puisqu'elle s'appelle bonne
pioche
elle avait lancé un tournage en
antarctique
une histoire de pingouins et au bout de
deux mois ils pouvaient plus payer
personne et l'histoire de pingouins
c'est la marche de l'empereur
c'est oscar à hollywood qui était
vraiment une belle réussite
mais il était bien incapable de me payer
donc j'ai dû me débrouiller et pendant
comme ça pendant quelques
quelques je dirais quelques années avant
que les chaînes commencent à venir
heureusement on ne voyage au début après
il ya quand même plus et puis c'est
france 5 qui a fait connaître cette
cette série et moi je dis ce qui est
très important c'est d'y aller et y
croire d'abord pour ne pas avoir de
regret quand tu avais ton idée comme ça
parce que sinon tu te dis gillet pas
puis dix ans plus tard tu dis c'était
peut-être une bonne idée
voire pire il ya un mec qui l'a fait ça
donc moi je voulais pas que ça m'arrive
et puis au fil de tous ces tournages de
j'irai dormir chez vous espèce de
combativité s'est encore entretenu parce
que je tombé en panne par exemple en
moto dans le sud de l'ethiopie
alors le but donc je pousse normalement
un individu normal se dit proche dans
une galère j'ai fait 40 degrés il n'y a
personne tu sais pas comment tu vas
faire nous pas drôle sauf que là je
filme et il se passe une chose c'est que
quand tout se passe bien pour moi les
gens qui regardent le film après ils
sont contents mais j'ai remarqué comme
ça se passait mal ils sont encore plus
content
ça c'est pas sympa et donc je pousse ma
moto mais je sais que j'ai une bonne
cinq séquences me rappelle d'une mouche
qui se pose là tu vois je les clac
je la rate je me fous une grande claque
je sais que les gens sont contents
pendant que je me pousse ma moto en
sueur par 40 degrés et il faut vraiment
se battre tout le temps et moi j'aime
bien cette histoire il ya quelqu'un il y
avait un navigateur qui était assez
connus qui s'appelait bernard moitessier
et je sais qu'il ya un ami à lui qui
voulait avoir comme lui un bateau et qui
avait pas d'argent et un jour ils
étaient dans le port est peut-être bien
que c'était à marseille et il voit une
coque qui était qui avait coulé à trois
mètres de profondeur et il se dit bah je
vais descendre avec des bidons d'air je
vais les mettre dedans puis quand il en
aura plein de bateaux on va remonter et
il a commencé à faire ça pendant des
jours et des jours
il fallait vraiment avoir de la
constance et de la volonté et basse gala
il a eu son bateau mais il n'a pas eu
son bateau comme on le croirait c'est
qu'un jour il parlait avec un mec de
tout en dotant entend régulièrement ils
ont commencé à être un peu ami pilote
était un peu impressionné par cette
volonté et un jour il lui a dit écoute
moi je suis vieux je n'ai pas d'enfant
j'ai un bateau je te le donne et ça
c'est vraiment je trouve ça illustre
très bien ce que c'est que la
combativité tu te bats pour quelque
chose
tu sais pas si ça va marcher mais tu
auras tout le temps quelque chose ça
c'est sûr on va remarquer ces qualités
là et moi je pense qu'il ya un truc qui
est très important si possible c'est
d'avoir le sentiment d'avoir réussi sa
vie réussir sa vie ça veut pas dire
simplement avoir gagné de l'argent ça
veut pas dire c'est être content de ce
qu'on fait je dirais moi quelqu'un qui
aime petite vie tranquille et tout et ça
lui convient et ben je dis bravo
et pour terminer jeudi que le truc le
plus important c'est pas de gagner des
sous pour une raison très simple c'est
qu'on va tous mourir
et quand on va mourir ici ce sera drôle
mais quand on va mourir il ya beaucoup
plus de chances qu'on parte avec nos
souvenirs qu'avec nos économies
ce à méditer le
j'ai fini
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]